welcome back everybody our next guest is
a board-certified plastic surgeon in
beverly hills california
and the creator of the true curve
brazilian butt lift
and body contouring technique perfect
timing as we all want to look and feel
our best as the weather gets warmer
right here
in vegas let's welcome dr dos to the
show hi
hi thanks for having me on of course of
course i understand that the true curve
results is
dramatic they're dramatic results but
very natural looking right
that's correct now i i created the true
curve brazilian butt lift to really
sculpt the entire body and create
beautiful proportions for
each woman doing his liposuction of the
midsection
to create a really tiny waist then i
transfer the fat to the buttock to
reshape it
and sculpt it into a beautiful shape i
fill in the
hips on the sides to get rid of the
indentions oh wow
the result is a beautifully dramatic
figure
that looks very feminine very natural
and i'm so impressed by the video you're
showing
yeah so my uh i'm sorry the video yeah
there's a video of one of
one of your we're showing you one of
your buttons yeah
it's looking great yeah as you can see
it's it's beautiful it's dramatic
yet the shape is very natural and you
know my philosophy is not it's not
just about the buttock but really
sculpting the entire body
to create beautiful proportions and
who's a good candidate for the true
curve brazilian butt lift or the body
contouring
great question you know is i mean it's
an excellent procedure for
anyone that has a little extra stubborn
fat around the mid section
which you know is a lot of us right
problem areas and what about patients
most frequently
you know as services what are they
asking for
well i i you know even during this time
of the pandemic as it's resolving
you know we're still seeing a huge
demand for the brazilian butt lifts
body contouring and pretty much a lot of
the cosmetic procedures that we perform
including breast augmentation tummy
tucks
the necklace see the nand has still been
really high for body contouring and it's
been great
and the patients really love it and dr
dos i thought
i saw a few photos of before and after
of the neck lift let's talk about that
describe the technique and and what that
does for people
absolutely the mini necklift is a great
procedure to really contour and define
the neck and jaw
line and the result is really again
very dramatically beautiful it creates
more youthfulness
and beauty in fact i see a lot of
younger patients coming to me even in
their 20s and 30s
to get more definition along their chin
now what i'm doing is liposuction
just to get rid of that little double
chin there even the smallest amount it
makes a huge difference in the face
and then i use a laser under the skin to
tighten the skin
so that way that lays down very
beautifully and
like i said the results are beautiful
well i
the proof is right there on the screen
your photo your before and after photos
are great so thank you so much for
sharing this information
thank you yeah i get uh you know i get a
lot of patience from
even the vegas area coming out to
beverly hills and actually
from all over the country because again
the demand is great and they love the
results
um yeah it's it's a great procedure
yeah and who wouldn't want a little trip
to beverly hills thank you so much dr
dos
all right for more information visit
dosmd.com or just call
das
1-855-496-4646